>>> BREAKING NEWS.
FORMER-PRESIDENT TRUMP HIT WITH
TWO NEW LAWSUITS FROM POLICE
OFFICERS WHO RESPONDED TO THE
JANUARY 6th ATTACK ALLEGING
TRUMP DIRECTED THE ASSAULT, THAT
LEFT THEM INJURED AND
TRAUMATIZED.
IT COMES AS SOME OF THE PEOPLE
WHO RIOTED THAT DAY REMAIN
DEFIANT SAYING THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WRONG AND THEY HAVE NO
REGRETS.
JESSICA SCHNEIDER IS OUT FRONT.
>> ASK ME IF I WOULD DO IT
AGAIN, I WANT TO SAY YES BUT
THEN I QUESTION IN THE BACK OF
MY HEAD WOULD I?
>> Reporter: FORMER PROUD BOY
JOSH PRUITT DESCRIBES HIS PAST
YEAR AS AN EMOTIONAL TRAIN
WRECK.
>> I DON'T FEEL I DID ANYTHING
WRONG BUT KNOWING THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT CAME OUT OF IT
WOULD BE THE PART THAT WOULD
MAKE ME QUESTION IT.
>> Reporter: PROSECUTORS HAVE
LAID OUT ON ARRAY OF VIDEO AS
EVIDENCE AGAINST HIM.
PRUITT CAN BE SEEN CONFRONTING
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICERS, AFTER
WALKING IN THROUGH THE SHATTERED
FRONT DOORS.
AND INSIDE THE CAPITOL CRYPT,
PRUITT IS CAUGHT SMASHING A
SIGN.
ALL OF IT, LEADING TO EIGHT
FEDERAL CHARGES AGAINST HIM,
INCLUDING COUNTS FOR DESTRUCTION
OF GOVERNMENT PROPERTY AND ACTS
OF PHYSICAL VIOLENCE.
BUT PRUITT DEFENDS HIS ACTIONS
THAT DAY.
CLINGING TO THE BIG LIE THAT
FORMER-PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
CONTINUES TO SPREAD, AND SAYING
HE HAS NO PLANS TO PLEAD GUILTY.
>> I WAS JUST A PATRIOT OUT
THERE, YOU KNOW, UM, PROTESTING
AGAINST WHAT I THINK IS A STOLEN
ELECTION.
TRYING TO SEND ME TO PRISON FOR
A FEW YEARS OVER THIS, I THINK
IS A COMPLETE JOKE.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT YOU
COULD BE, IN FACT, SENT TO
PRISON?
>> I AM CONCERNED.
>> Reporter: PRUITT IS AMONG THE
MORE THAN 700 PEOPLE NOW CHARGED
IN CONNECTION WITH THE CAPITOL
ATTACK.
70-PLUS DEFENDANTS HAVE BEEN
SENTENCED, SO FAR.
ABOUT 30, GETTING JAIL TIME.
>> THE FIRST WEEK IN JANUARY, I
HAVE TO REPORT TO PRISON.
>> Reporter: JENNA RYAN FLEW A
PRIVATE JET TO WASHINGTON, AND
NOTABLY BOASTED THAT STORMING
THE CAPITOL WAS ONE OF THE BEST
DAYS OF HER LIFE.
HER LACK OF REMORSE, IN PART,
PROMPTED A JUDGE TO IMPOSE A
60-DAY SENTENCE AFTER SHE
PLEADED GUILTY TO A MISDEMEANOR.
THE JUDGE SAYING HE WANTED TO
MAKE AN EXAMPLE OF HER, AFTER
SHE SHAMELESSLY TWEETED THAT SHE
WOULDN'T GET JAIL TIME SINCE SHE
HAS BLONDE HAIR, WHITE SKIN, AND
DID NOTHING WRONG.
>> ALL THOSE 600 PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED ARE NOW
WONDERING WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THEM AND PRISON IS --
CAN HAPPEN.
>> Reporter: SEVERAL OF THOSE
SENTENCED ARE EXPRESSING
REMORSE.
ERIC ROW GOT 45 DAYS IN JAIL
AFTER PLEADING GUILTY TO JUST
ONE COUNT OF DISORDERLY CONDUCT.
THE FEDERAL JUDGE ADMONISHED ROW
FOR TRYING TO UNDERMINE THE
PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
PRESIDENTIAL POWER, WHAT HE
CALLED ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S
BEDROCK ACTS.
HE STRUGGLED TO SPEAK AT
SENTENCING TELLING THE JUDGE,
THERE IS NO DISUEXCUSE FOR MY
ACTIONS ON JANUARY 6th.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MUCH THIS
HAS JUST TWISTED MY STOMACH
EVERY DAY SINCE IT HAPPENED.
ANOTHER RIOTER, ROBERT READER,
GOT THREE MONTHS IN JAIL.
DURING HIS SENTENCING, HE
PLEADED WITH THE JUDGE SAYING HE
LOST HIS FAMILY, HIS JOB, AND
HIS PLACE WITHIN HIS CHURCH
COMMUNITY AFTER JANUARY 6th.
I AM EMBARRASSED, I AM IN SHAME,
READER SAID.
THE HURT THAT I HAVE CAUSED
OTHER PEOPLE, NOT JUST TO
MYSELF, HAS LEFT A PERMANENT
STAIN ON ME.
SOCIETY, THE COUNTRY, AND I
DON'T WANT TO BE EVER REMEMBERED
FOR BEING PART OF THAT CROWD.
JOSH PRUITT, THOUGH, STILL ISN'T
WILLING TO ADMIT GUILT OR
COOPERATE WITH PROSECUTORS.
VIDEO OF PRUITT PLEDGING TO
BECOME A MEMBER OF THE PROUD
BOYS IN NOVEMBER 2020 WENT
VIRAL.
PRUITT SAYS PROSECUTORS ARE
ASKING HIM TO HELP MAKE THE CASE
AGAINST OTHER PROUD BOYS FACING
CONSPIRACY CHARGES BUT HE CLAIMS
HE NO LONGER ASSOCIATES WITH THE
EXTREMIST GROUP.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANYBODY TO THROW
UNDER THE BUS, NOR WOULD I
ANYWAY.
UM, AND I JUST -- WHAT I AM
SAYING DOESN'T FIT THEIR
NARRATIVE BECAUSE THEY WOULD
LIKE ME TO COME FORWARD AND SAY
THAT IT WAS PLANNED.
AND I'M LIKE NO, IT WASN'T.
EVERYBODY THINKS THAT WE HAD ALL
THESE PLANS GOING INTO THIS.
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
I WAS IN TOUCH WITH SOME PRETTY
RIGHT-WING PEOPLE, AND WE NEVER
HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
>> Reporter: WHILE PRUITT WAITS
OUT HIS NEXT COURT DATE, HE
SPENDS MOST OF HIS DAYS INSIDE
HIS NASHVILLE APARTMENT WEARING
AN ANKLE BRACELET AND ABIDING BY
A 9:00 P.M. CURFEW EXCEPT WHEN
HE IS WORKING AS A BARTENDER,
SOMETHING THAT IS APPROVED BY
THE COURT.
PRUITT EXPECTS HIS CASE TO GO TO
TRIAL, AND SAYS HE STILL STANDS
BY THE BIG LIE.
>> FOR SURE.
>> AND DO YOU STILL BELIEVE
THAT?
>> I STILL BELIEVE IT.
>> Reporter: AND PRUITT ISN'T
THE ONLY ONE I SPOKE WITH
SEVERAL ACCUSED RIOTERS ON THE
PHONE.
THEY WOULDN'T GO ON CAMERA
BECAUSE OF THEIR PENDING CASES
OR THE FACT THEY WANTED TO STAY
OUT OF THE SPOTLIGHT.
BUT THE HANDFUL THAT I SPOKE
WITH, ERIN, SAY THEY STILL
BELIEVE THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IT WAS JUST PRO-TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WHO STORMED THE
CAPITOL THAT DAY.
THEY TRIED TO TELL ME THAT THEY
ALSO BELIEVE IT WAS MOSTLY
MEMBERS OF ANTIFA.
IN THE MEANTIME, ERIN, THE FBI
IS STILL GOING STRONG IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
THEIR LATEST NUMBERS THEY SAY
THEY ARE STILL SEARCHING FOR
ABOUT 350 PEOPLE ACCUSED OF
VIOLENT ACTS RIGHT HERE AT THE
CAPITOL.
ERIN?
>> INCREDIBLE THAT THEY ARE
STILL SEARCHING IN THIS COUNTRY
FOR 350 PEOPLE.
INCREDIBLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE ENTIRE REPORT.
I WANT TO BRING IN MICHAEL
FANONE, FORMER 20 YEAR VETERAN
OF THE D.C. METROPOLITAN POLICE,
AND OF COURSE, YOU WERE
VICIOUSLY ATTACKED BY RIOTERS AS
YOU PROTECTED THE CAPITOL.
THIS IS SO PEOPLE CAN SEE YOU IN
THE MIDST OF THIS.
YOU KNOW, DRAGGED IN THAT CROWD
AND YOU, OF COURSE, ARE NOW A
LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST HERE
WITH US, AND I AM GRATEFUL TO
HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW.
SO, AURZ THERE AND YOU ARE
FEARING FOR YOUR LIFE, AND THEN
YOU HEAR THIS REPORT -- THIS
RIOTER SAY HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
UM, THAT HE WOULD MAYBE EVEN DO
IT AGAIN.
HOW DOES THAT EVEN PROCESS
THROUGH YOUR MIND?
>> I MEAN, I COULDN'T CARE LESS
ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL RIOTERS OR
INSURRECTIONISTS' PERSPECTIVE ON
THAT DAY.
THE ONLY THING THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN WITH REGARDS TO
THEIR BEHAVIOR IS
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IF THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT THEY
COMMITTED A CRIME, UM, I WANT
THEM TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THOSE CRIMES.
>> NOW OF COURSE, YOU MENTION --
YEAH, GO AHEAD.
GO AHEAD.
FINISH YOUR POINT.
>> IF THEY ARE REMORSEFUL OF THE
TIME, YOU KNOW, FOR THE -- TO
PLEAD FOR THE MERCY OF THE COURT
IS AT SENTENCING AND IF THEY'RE
NOT, YOU KNOW, FEEL FREE TO --
TO LET THE JUDGE KNOW THAT
YOU'RE NOT REMORSEFUL FOR YOUR
ACTIONS.
>> AND, YOU KNOW, SHE MENTIONED,
WHAT, MORE THAN 300 PEOPLE THAT
THEY ARE STILL LOOKING FOR.
I -- I FIND THAT SHOCKING,
MICHAEL, AND I THINK TO MYSELF,
YOU HAVE THE FBI ON THIS.
YOU HAVE GOT HUNDREDS OF HOURS
OF VIDEO AND -- AND 300 PEOPLE
WHO STORMED THE CAPITOL THAT
THEY WANT TO CHARGE, THEY CAN'T
FIND.
AND I KNOW YOU ARE SAYING THIS
IS ACCOUNTABILITY IS WHAT REALLY
MATTERS.
AND ANOTHER OFFICER WHO YOU
TESTIFIED WITH, UM, SAID EARLIER
IF THE PEOPLE WHO PERPETRATED
THE ATTACK AREN'T BROUGHT TO
JUSTICE, THEN -- THEN IT'S NOT
ACCOUNTABILITY, THEN IT COULD
HAPPEN AGAIN.
LET ME JUST PLAY WHAT OFFICER
GONELL SAID.
>> HOLD PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE ACCOUNTABLE,
INCLUDING THOSE ELECTED
OFFICIALS BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T
DO THAT, THIS MIGHT BE A
RECURRING ISSUE EVERY FOUR
YEARS.
>> THUS FAR, MICHAEL, RIGHT,
IT'S -- IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
ACTUALLY THERE RIOTING, THE
INSURRECTIONISTS BEING CHARGED
AND 300 OF THEM, THEY CAN'T EVEN
FIND.
BUT -- BUT NONE OF THE
POLITICIANS WHO SAID THE WORDS
AND THE LIE THAT CAUSED ALL
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO BE THERE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY HOPE THAT THE
RIGHT PEOPLE WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE?
>> UM, YEAH, I MEAN, MY
EXPERIENCE AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER AND AS AMERICAN, I THINK
THAT, UM, UNFORTUNATELY, MANY OF
THESE POLITICIANS ARE GOING TO
GET AWAY BY HIDING BEHIND, YOU
KNOW, POLITICAL SPEAK AND, UM,
THE IDEA THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT
THEIR WORDS WERE -- WERE NOT
INTENTIONAL.
SO, NO, I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS GOING TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
THE PLANNING AND PREPARATION FOR
THAT DAY.
AND ALSO, THOSE WHOSE INCITEFUL
RHETORIC RESULTED IN THE
INSURRECTION AT THE CAPITOL.
>> SO, I KNOW THAT YOU -- YOU
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THAT DAY AND
OTHER OF YOUR COLLEAGUES HAVE,
AS WELL.
THE TRAUMA THAT IT CAUSED.
THE REAL TOLL IT CONTINUES TO
TAKE ON THEIR LIVES.
AND NOW, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU --
YOU LOOK THROUGH THAT, MORALE I
KNOW IS LOW.
STAFFING IN SHORT SUPPLY.
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER TOLD "THE
WASHINGTON POST," MICHAEL
SOMETHING YOU PROBABLY KNOW OF
COURSE BETTER THAN ANYONE BUT
THE QUOTE WAS THERE IS A DARK
CLOUD OVER CAPITOL HILL.
I LOOKED AT OFFICERS' FACES AND
THEY'VE CHANGED.
THE
THEY'VE LOST WEIGHT AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHY.
THE CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF,
MICHAEL, SAYS THE FORCE IS 400
OFFICERS SHORT.
400 OFFICERS SHORT.
AND -- AND THEY ARE CITING
FALLOUT FROM THE INSURRECTION.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM YOUR
FORMER COLLEAGUES?
>> WELL, I LEFT THE U.S. CAPITOL
POLICE A LONG TIME AGO, IN 2003.
UM, BUT I DO SPEAK TO QUITE A
FEW OFFICERS ON THE HILL AND I
KNOW FROM MY TIME THERE.
BUT WHAT I WITNESSED ON JANUARY
6th AND, YOU KNOW, SINCE THEN IN
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH
OFFICERS IS A -- A REAL CRISIS
IN LEADERSHIP WITHIN THE UNITED
STATES CAPITOL POLICE THAT I
DON'T THINK HAS YET TO BE
ADDRESSED.
IT -- IT WASN'T ADDRESSED, UM,
AT LEAST NOT DIRECTLY IN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
TALKED ABOUT PUBLICLY.
BUT THERE WAS A REAL FAILURE IN
LEADERSHIP AT THE EXECUTIVE
LEVEL OR AT THE COMMAND LEVEL
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES CAPITOL
POLICE.
AND UNTIL THAT'S ADDRESSED, I
DON'T SEE MORALE IMPROVING AND I
CERTAINLY DON'T SEE THE AGENCY
RETAINING OFFICERS WHO FEEL LIKE
THEY'VE BEEN ABANDONED BY THEIR
COMMAND-LEVEL OFFICIALS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK THAT
DEMANDS RESIGNATIONS.